hallo meine lieben ich möchte euch heute
mit auf ein konzert nehmen denn ich war
in heidelberg auf dem eko fresh konzert
und ich zeige euch jetzt einfach mal
wenig dort alles getroffen habe und vor
allen dingen möchte ich euch endlich
verraten wer meinen wundervollen
weihnachts song gesungen hat
sie denken
ok also ich war heute ein heidelberg und
es war mein allererstes konzert mein
allererstes web konzept vor allen dingen
und neben mir steht auto erkennt ihn
wahrscheinlich vielleicht so nicht weil
ich glaube meine zuschauer sind
wahrscheinlich nicht so die rap fans
aber wenn ihr jetzt heute hier gewesen
wären und welche ihr wahrscheinlich
jetzt trend geworden und ich muss sagen
ich habe die songs auf der cd gehört da
waren sie schon gut und live und in
deutschland besser wirklich das volk
nicht sally hatten kulturschock bekommen
weil ich glaube das was heute passiert
ist war sich nicht gewohnt aber hast du
ich glaube ich kann ich habe ich gedacht
ich komm' ich hier rein und da gibt es
sitzplätze vielleicht ein buffet
stehplätze sport
er war richtig meine ich allzu lang
und ich wollte jetzt auch sagen wo ist
der zusammenhang zwischen leonardo
vielleicht habt ihr es an der stimme
erkannt haben vor ein bisschen
mitgefilmt hat nämlich mein winter vom
geschrieben und auch selber gesungen
kann schon kurz an stimmen
jetzt kurz die regierung also
die engel warten kekse der himmel rot es
ist entspannter
und genau so ungefähr ich jetzt gleich
noch einen austritt jetzt nicht alle
gerüchte dass murat den song gesungen
hat stimme nächste stufe post zu buche
aber ich war dieser okay aber ich glaube
schon allem vor kurzem rausgebracht ja
jetzt also
aber wenn ich das video mache dann ist
es also mein albums jetzt verkaufen
herausgekommen das heißt reise erstes
haus bekommen und man kann es halt
überall kaufen und wirklich freuen wenn
ihr damals ein hört es wirkt nationen
ist eine bonus tracks die staatenwelt
drauf leider noch nicht aber das kommt
sicherlich dieses jahr alles klar
nochmal zink silber
ich kann alles aber nicht singen
ändert es nichts daran
steuern
der streit
nicht nur
ich hab' ich bin
ich will